don't know how old it is but it's the
real deal you've been in a medically
induced
all right i need to get to sanjay it
seems you need an introduction i was
almost taken out by a very unusual the
garcia mendez villains from was actually
the information that i helped default
storage facility for art that was
acquired
it's sort of like a transit lounge for
us they used to hang around the west
side of the front display to turn style
in there then i tried to look the only
used
russian missile station was over taking
plutonium from the rubbles
the ia provides two thirds of the market
for the facility is flooded with
after which it was used for underground
tests
backwards so to our eyes as they
approach the first atomic test
this video is sponsored by audible
christopher nolan is a director who
places a massive amount of emphasis on
the visual element of filmmaking
he frequently shoots with bulky loud and
difficult to operate imax and 70
millimeter cameras just to eke out some
extra visual clarity he creates
incredible real set pieces like the
fields of corn grown just so he can
drive a truck through them for
interstellar
the actual rotating hallways for
inception or a real plane crash
for tenant all this because nolan
believes how a film looks matters
what you see on screen and the reality
and vibrancy of what you're seeing
is extremely important to him so it
strikes me as incredibly odd that for
all his emphasis on
image he's often not a director who's
willing to rely
only on visual storytelling instead he
often adds or uses exposition
in addition to or instead of visual
storytelling we pass it through the bulk
space beyond our three dimensions all
you can do is record and observe
exposition itself is by no means
inherently bad it can be used well
and nolan has used it in both compelling
and bad ways but i want to focus on
three of his films inception
interstellar and tenant and show how i
think his incredible reliance on
exposition has led to disastrous results
with tenant this video has spoilers for
tenant and interstellar
there's tenant spoilers throughout but
i've marked the interstellar spoilers so
you can skip over them if you haven't
seen it
nolan has always been a filmmaker who
has focused on conceptual stories
and conceptual storytelling he's
interested in creating scenarios that
bend the rules of time and space
either in how he presents a story
narratively or by
actually bending time and space in the
fictional reality of the story
this level of complexity both in the
stories themselves and
in the storytelling creates a potential
problem it's possible the audience might
have difficulty
understanding what's going on one way to
deal with this issue is by using visual
storytelling devices to help the
audience understand the concept
nolan does this in inception's opening
the inner cutting between the levels of
the dream and the use of watches
slowing down and speeding up helps
introduce us to the idea that time runs
slower in the dreams
another way to deal with the issue of
complexity is by having a character
explain the concept through exposition
dream your mind functions more quickly
therefore
time seems to feel more slow five
minutes in the real world gives you an
hour in the dream
christopher nolan utilizes both
frequently while i think visual
storytelling that helps us understand a
concept is usually more satisfying for a
viewer we all know the old adage
show don't tell showing is more
complicated and difficult than telling
and almost every film uses
exposition to some degree the key is to
only use it when necessary
and to hide it when you do use it
there are many ways a filmmaker can hide
exposition from an audience but let's
look at three common characteristics of
good
hidden exposition so we can better
understand when exposition goes wrong
when what's being explained in the
exposition is a new
interesting concept that the audience
isn't familiar with then it's
less of a potential problem for the
audience people regularly consume
content that is primarily exposition
like podcasts or
news because they're interested in
what's being explained so there's no
reason
a film can't be used to explain an
interesting concept
when one character has a realistic
reason to be saying what they're saying
to another character the exposition
feels
more natural and believable in inception
it makes sense that cobb is explaining
how various parts of the dream worlds
work
to ariadne you can literally talk to my
subconscious that's one of the ways we
extract information
because she doesn't know anything about
those worlds and tenant
when this woman is explaining inversion
to the protagonist one of these bullets
is like us
traveling forwards through time the
other one's going backwards
it makes sense because he has no idea
what it is and she's someone who's been
studying it
nolan often uses what screenwriting
educator blake snyder calls the pope in
the pool method of exposition
by setting exposition during other
interesting events
it helps keep the audience occupied with
interesting
settings and situations while exposition
is being fed
to the audience drone solar cells can
power an entire farm
nolan does this constantly by setting
expositional conversations and scenes
with movement or
activity that is relevant to the
exposition i personally don't think pope
in the pool is enough on its own to make
exposition good
if the exposition isn't motivated or
interesting the audience will still
notice it even if pope in the pool is
being utilized but if your exposition is
motivated and interesting
utilizing this method can help keep it
hidden nolan doesn't always follow these
guidelines
though the three films i'm talking about
in this video are filled with noticeable
exposition
i'll show you how it works sometimes we
see examples of unmotivated exposition
here cooper is an engineer and would
already know what a wormhole is
so a wormhole bends space like this so
you can take a shortcut through
a higher dimension it doesn't make any
sense that he'd be learning this for the
first time in space
mission already underway unmotivated
exposition
sticks out like a sore thumb because if
there's no reason for one character to
say what they're saying to another the
audience realizes that the only reason
the character is saying those lines is
to convey information to the audience
gravity on that planet will slow our
clock compared to earth's
drastically wow well
every hour we spend on that planet will
be
seven years back on earth
that's relativity folks this pulls back
the curtain on storytelling in a way
that can be disruptive to the experience
of watching a film
nolan also often uses exposition for
unnecessary or uninteresting things the
main way he falls into this trap is when
he has characters explaining things that
have already been clearly explained or
are visually obvious on screen examples
of this include
arthur sang paradox for no conceivable
reason here
paradox other than to
just remind the audience of a concept
that was explained earlier
and one which is being visually
communicated very well
paradox or cooper and interstellar
saying frozen cloud
after their ship bumps into what can
really only be interpreted as a frozen
cloud just by looking at it
frozen cloud tenant has some really bad
examples of this
this line just comes across as dumb and
unnecessary if your particles come into
contact
what annihilation that will be bad right
not only are most audience members going
to know that annihilation is bad but
there's no way a high-level special
operative wouldn't know that this one is
so bad i feel like it might be nolan's
attempt at humor but the context and the
delivery really makes it feel like it's
not a joke
these are only a few small examples but
these three films are littered with
these kinds of small
unnecessary and noticeable expositional
moments that take you out of the story
but while exposition that is noticeable
bothers me it's not the end of the world
for a film
noticeable exposition however isn't the
only problem with interstellar
and tenant don't try to understand it
feel it
in exploring big crandios concepts and
ideas with his films nolan is often
encountering or portraying things that
would be difficult to wrap
our heads around if we encountered them
in real life something like
five-dimensional space and how gravity
moves through time
or how causality could work in reverse
are not ideas we can quickly
intuitively understand rationally
fortunately i think film is a great
medium for conveying ideas
feelings and concepts that we don't
fully understand
christopher nolan thinks so too listen
to what he has to say about the
tesseract scene and
interstellar the complexity of it is
something that i don't think the
audience would be able to grasp while
they're watching the film because it's
based on the concept of
suppressing a spatial dimension and
substituting time for one of the special
dimensions
creating an array that can display time
as a spatial dimension
but my feeling was very strongly that if
we
knew what the rule set was and how it
would work mathematically
and if we were true to that in building
the set
and then in conceiving of how the visual
effects will expand the set that the
audience would feel
a logic behind it
tenant's inversion concept works this
way if you try to think about how moving
through
inverted time works it's really
difficult to wrap your head around that
rationally
but when you see it portrayed on screen
you can intuitively
feel how it works enough for the action
to be satisfying
and make some amount of sense but here's
the problem we use a different part of
our brain to
feel and experience what's happening in
a film than we do to rationally try to
understand a concept
i think it's difficult for these two
things to happen simultaneously it's one
of the reasons if you're analyzing the
filmmaking of a film
it's difficult to simultaneously be
engaged emotionally in the film
the climax of interstellar has a perfect
example of this
how nolan conveys this idea visually is
incredibly compelling
while we can't really wrap our heads
around it logically it makes a certain
intuitive sense visually and we can
understand the mechanics of what is
happening
enough for the story to progress it also
gives us the feeling of experiencing
something incomprehensible which is what
the characters are experiencing
it helps create a feeling of awe wonder
and mystery
and yet nolan undercuts these feelings
and our intuitive sense of what's
happening by insisting on explaining
what's going on with exposition
they saved us
what the hell is they and just why they
want to help us huh
i don't know but they constructed this
three-dimensional space inside their
five-dimensional reality to allow you to
understand it
well that ain't working not only does
the exposition feel forced in this
moment but it forces the audience
out of a feeling experiencing mode and
into a thinking mode
and condensing this wild and incredible
experience into something that can be
quickly summarized through exposition
just cheapens it while i think this
exposition
undercuts some of the emotional weight
of interstellar's climax
it doesn't ruin the film completely the
explanation that's provided in the
exposition
does at least make some sense tenant
however
is a different story nolan again clearly
understands that inversion is something
the audience will have to
feel as they see it don't try to
understand it
feel it and yet he's constantly
insisting on explaining aspects of
inversion to us throughout the whole
film
you mean reverse chronology like firemen
and weirdest notion of positrons and
electrons moving backwards in time
in a parallel world's theory we can't
know the relationship between
consciousness and multiple realities
these explanations could just be
annoying and bothersome
to the pacing or emotion of the film
like they are
in inception and interstellar
yes but at least for me most of them
just make inversion itself more
confusing
all the explaining forces me to try to
think about and
understand what's going on in the film
conceptually
instead of just letting me feel it which
harms the film for me
but even this use of exposition to
explain the concept
i could forgive if things stopped there
i've criticized how noticeable the
exposition is and
how much it's used in all three films
but i still find
interstellar and inception enjoyable to
watch however there are two
new ways that nolan misuses exposition
in tenant
that really harms the film i connect
with inception and interstellar because
in spite of their exposition issues they
have emotionally
grounded and motivated characters in
inception cobb is trying to get back
with his children and is struggling with
his wife mal
this emotional character motivation is
established partly through cobb telling
the story of his past but it's also
something we get to
see cobb's emotional motivation and
conflict
is something that's established through
scenes where performance
allows us to see the emotional stakes
for the character
in interstellar cooper's emotional
motivation is
also similarly grounded on screen
[Music]
the emotional stakes of the film are
clearly grounded in performance that we
get to see
in tenet however we get almost none of
this instead nolan leans
almost entirely on exposition for any
kind of emotional
character motivation or development he's
a cute kid
he's everything this is embodied most
clearly through what is the film's worst
and most laughable line
everyone and everything that's ever
lived destroyed
precise enough including my son
nolan clearly knows he needs to give his
characters personal
and emotional stakes and this is his
attempt to do so but this time instead
of
showing these stakes on screen he just
has the characters
say them out loud is everything this is
also how
seder's motivations are handled he
supposedly wants to end his life and
take the whole world with him
no you've missed the point
he's intending to end his life but we
don't get to see
why he feels this way we're just told
about it he's taking the world with him
if he can't happen no one can this also
applies to the protagonist he goes to
extreme lengths just to help cat i'm
taking her through
i'm not gonna let her die i'll take my
chances but we never see anything to
justify
why he cares enough about her to risk
his life and the mission
for her especially when he's already
expressed that he's willing to make
compromises
for a mission would you take a child
hostage
a woman if i had to his friendship with
neil is ripe for
emotional motivation or stakes but it
goes completely unutilized besides just
being a clever twist
i think this is the end of a beautiful
friendship but for me it's just the
beginning
let me get up to some stuff you're gonna
love it
you'll see
i've been criticizing the film non-stop
so let me pause and highlight what i
think is one of the few
genuine moments of visual character
development at the beginning of the film
we get the setup about cat
seeing another woman dive off the yacht
i never felt such envy
you don't seem a jealous type of freedom
fast forward to the end of the film
where future cat is on the boat in the
past here nolan lets us watch and see
kat make the decision to linger for a
few minutes before she dives
choosing to let her past self see her
future self
intentionally planting the seed of envy
and we realize without need for an
explanation
that kat was the woman who dived off the
boat
it's a great moment and a big part of
why it's so great is that we can
understand
and feel this climax and cat's character
arc and the emotion
and weight of the decision she's making
without being told in
inception and interstellar there are
many moments like this where a major
plot element is revealed visually so
that we get to recognize the character
and plot developments for ourselves
instead of just being told about them
antennae however besides the example i
just showed you and maybe a few others
most of the major plot developments are
revealed in exposition
for example take the very significant
reveal that the protagonist
has been working for himself the whole
time i realized i wasn't working for you
we've both been working for me
there's no visual clue for this we don't
see why he's realized this we don't see
any kind of emotional impact that this
realization has had on him he just tells
us that he realized it
it makes the plot revelations way less
satisfying and impactful
and finally it just adds an absurd
amount of
sheer volume to the exposition in the
film nolan is already using exposition
to explain
the concept and the rules of inversion
and he's also using exposition to
establish the character's motivations
and emotional stakes of the film and
when in addition to all that he uses
exposition to explain the film's
convoluted plot
instead of showing us the revelations
and details it all just
mushes together into an exhausting
onslaught of exposition that is
periodically
interrupted by some of the most
inventive action scenes i've seen in a
movie in a long time
what's most frustrating is that we know
nolan is capable of good visual
storytelling
and dunkirk there's almost no dialogue
and he relies on it almost entirely
but in tenent i think he relies on it
way too much and for me personally
it ran what would otherwise be a great
movie into the ground
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video earlier in the video i talk about
the pope in the pool method of
exposition and you can learn about that
method
in blake snyder's save the cat you could
get this audiobook for free when you
sign up with
a 30 day free trial by going to
audible.com
thomasflight or texting thomasflight2500
500.
when you do that you'll get one free
credit that you can spend on any
audiobook i'm currently listening to the
queen's gambit i talked about queen's
gamut a few weeks ago and if you enjoyed
the show you could listen to the novel
that the series is based on in addition
to the one credit you'll get every month
to spend on
audiobook you get unlimited access to
the new audible plus catalog
which has a bunch of exclusive podcasts
audible originals and other spoken word
content
i'm a big fan of audiobooks i'll often
throw them on while i'm cooking or
cleaning or while i'm doing mundane
video editing
and it's a great way to pass the time
and make those tasks more enjoyable
audible has an unmatched selection of
audiobooks so you should try it out for
free today by going to audible.com
thomasflight clicking the link in the
description or texting
thomasflight2500 500. thanks again to
audible for sponsoring this video
thank you so much to my patrons for
their ongoing support if you're
interested
in supporting my channel on an ongoing
basis and getting some bonus content
go to patreon.com thomasflight
[Music]